MATT PARKER: I'd like to talk
to you about the number 98.
98 is a bit large for
people to think it's
quite a cool number.
However, if you take
the square root of
98, it equals 9.89949.
What I like is that the first
two digits are the same as the
digits in the number you were
taking the square root.
This works for other numbers.
If you take the square root
of 99, it equals 9.94999.
Starts with 99.
And when I saw this,
I saw 98 first.
I thought, wait a minute, I
wonder if there are other
bigger ones.
And it turns out there are.
If you take the square root of
9998, that equals 99.98999.
And there's your 9998.
And all these numbers-- and
you can keep going.
9999, if you square root
9999, it starts 99.99.
And there's other stuff
going out there.
But it starts with those.
And this continues.
The next one, it's always
an even number of nines.
So 9999, and then ending
with an 8.
And 9999, ending with a nine.
You've got these numbers where,
if you take their
square root, they begin with
exactly the same digits.
Admittedly, only in base 10.
But I was just doing
this in Excel.
I made a little spreadsheet,
and I was putting
in all these numbers.
And I found these.
And I went, I wonder
if there are more?
And I couldn't find any more
where the square root starts
with exactly the same digits
as the number itself.
But then I went, you know what,
I wonder if there any
numbers where just after the
decimal point, maybe just the
digits after there are the same
as the number itself.
And there are.
I'll just do a couple.
The first one is 77.
Because if you do the square
root of 77, it starts with 8,
which is a bit disappointing.
But then 77 appears
right there.
And, in fact, any number--
so 9797, and then 997997.
And this pattern continues
all the way down.
Each of those, this one is 98.
You ignore that.
It then goes 9797
and then I think
it's like 95 or something.
But this here, so there's 77.
There's 9797.
This one here starts 998.
We ignore that.
And then you've got 997997,
and then a bunch of stuff
after that.
But there it is.
I find these weird properties
of numbers fascinating.
And again, I'd never
heard of this.
No one ever talked to me about
numbers where the decimals in
the number appear in
its square root.
I looked online, I couldn't find
anyone else talking about
these sorts of numbers.
I asked some friends.
No one had heard of these.
And I was like, well, I've got
to call them something because
I was making notes on them.
I was looking into
different types.
And so I called them grafting
numbers, because you start
with a number and then its root
just grows off from it.
However, up until now, they're
being quite boring.
Because there's these
two families.
There's the 98 family and the
77 family, which is a quite
predictable series of numbers.
And I wanted to see if were
more exciting ones.
So I thought, how am
I going to do this?
Up until now, I've been putting
this into Excel and
doing a spreadsheet.
And Excel is great, because you
can see the numbers that
you're doing calculations.
And you can search
for numbers.
But you hit the limits
quite quickly.
And so I thought, you know what,
I've been meaning to
learn how to program
in Python, which is
a programming language.
If you've done any programming,
I highly
recommend Python.
Don't go through life without
being able to program.
It's a whole area of a way of
thinking and a way of doing
things that underpins all
our modern technology.
At least, for a little while,
out of interest.
It's like everyone should
skydive once, because we're
the first generation of humans
that can jump off
that kind of a height.
You know, just a--
you know, this weekend
I'm going to fall
from a plane and survive.
No other human's been
able to do that.
So I programmed a
little script.
And I found all the numbers up
to 10 million which appear
somewhere in their root before
you go past the decimal point.
Because once you fall off
that decimal point, it
is a long way down.
It looks like it stopped, but
it's just checking bigger and
bigger numbers.
See, it's found a few more.
And it's checked the first
million at this point.
I'll show you the
ones I've found.
There's another-- and I'm not
going to bother with the
square root sign anymore, just
to make life easier.
764, its root is 27.64054
and so on.
And there it is there.
764 appears a little way in.
And in fact, 765 does the same
thing, 27.6586 and so on.
And there it is there, 765.
5711 gives you 75.57115,
and there it is
there, and that continues.
The next one down was 5736.
That gives you 75.73638
and so on.
And there it is there, 5736.
So in addition to the ones I
showed you before, these are
all the other numbers that
appear somewhere at the
beginning of the square root.
Now, mathematicians can be very
patronizing towards some
of the sciences.
In fact, physicists themselves
refer to biologists as people
doing stamp collecting, because
all they're doing is
looking at things and
just labeling them.
They're not doing any of the
underlying patterns or the
reasoning behind it.
And I, as much as I make fun of
biologists, I also do like
stamp collecting.
I like biology, for
the record.
And in maths, there's some
great fun doing stamp
collecting.
So these numbers are
meaningless, to be honest.
This only works in base 10.
There's no rhyme or reason.
It could be a complete accident
that 5711, its square
root starts 5711.
There could be absolutely
no meaning.
But I enjoyed writing a computer
program, as such, to
search through and to find
all these numbers.
But then the mathematician
in me thought, what
if there is a pattern?
What if there is something
underneath these?
And so I suddenly
looked at these.
I went, wait a minute.
This one here, 76394,
looks a lot like
this one here, 7639321.
In fact, it's the first five
digits of this, and then
rounded up, as such.
And then I went, wait a minute,
what if I take the
first three digits of this
and round that up.
And that's over here, 764.
And so it looked like there was
this pattern of numbers.
And so I wrote a different
program to just look for the
numbers of this form.
And I'll show you
what I found.
If you continue on, this pattern
does keep going.
The next one down-- where
we up to-- gets to 31.
The next one is 763932023.
That appears in its
square root.
The one after that
was 76393202251.
The next one is 7639320--
0, I'll make sure I
get this right--
0225003, from memory.
Yep.
And then the next one is a bit
longer, and a bit longer, and
a bit longer.
And it keeps going.
And there is this sequence
of numbers that have
the grafting property.
And I thought, well,
what is it?
And if you just take this string
of numbers, it turns
out this string of numbers is 3
minus the square root of 5.
If you work out 3 minus the
square root of 5 as a number,
it equals 0.763932.
And then it's exactly the
same sequence as far in
as you care to go.
So this family of grafting
numbers are
based on this constant.
And so I decided this--
I call it a grafting constant.
And if you take that number
and multiply it up.
So if you multiply it, well,
first of all, by 1,000 and
then round it up, you
get the first one.
If you multiply that by 100
and round it up, you
get the next one.
Multiply it by 100, get the
next one, and then so on.
You get-- there's
a whole family.
Actually, if you want to write
that mathematically, we'll put
that in brackets.
You're then going to have to
multiply this by 10 to the
power of 2n minus 1.
That will generate your
next term up.
And in maths, to say round
up, we do what's
called ceiling brackets.
So I'm going--
I'll do--
it's like, I draw
them like this.
There are variations.
It's calculate that, round
it up to the next number.
And you get a whole family
of grafting numbers.
So there you are.
I was very pleased because I
went from just being the
mathematical equivalent of a
trainspotter, pulling out
these random numbers, to finding
some that had an
underlying pattern, and the
constant that generates them.
And that made me
disproportionately happy.
And this may be number four.
I've not come across it, but
most things in maths have the
number four.
I was at the Maths Jam weekend,
which is the Maths
Jam conference.
So math jams are monthly
gatherings in pubs to do maths
and talk about fun things.
Once a year we get together,
so 130, not mathematicians,
just people who like maths,
were in a room.
And everyone gets five minutes
to talk about something that
they assume everyone else
will find interesting.
And I talked about
these numbers.
And some people just found the
programming aspect of finding
these, and just categorizing
them, was interesting.
But the mathematicians in the
room were a bit more pleased
when I could show that there's
a family which has an
underlying pattern to them.
And I don't know what happens.
I've thought, you could
look at them.
You could do cube roots.
You could do this in
different bases.
There's always another way
to generalize this
and see what happens.
BRADY HARAN: What do you
think about this?
What do you think I
MATT PARKER: I--
goodness knows.
My theory was that, as a
mathematician, my theory is
not that unusual.
Because I figure if you find
something interesting, someone
else will find something
interesting.
And I found these numbers
And well, I'm sure I'm unusual
in a lot of ways, but there
must be some other people who
find this stuff fascinating.
And so, I thought I'd
share it with them.
And some people did.
They thought it was great.
I sat on the train and learned
computer programming.